انفجار في
مدينة ماليتوبول بجنوب أوكرانيا
ألقت موسكو باللوم فيه على المقاومات الأوكرانية
وعلى الجيش يوم الأحد
في قلب بلدة
كانت في أيدي الروس لما يقرب من ثلاثة
أشهر ، تم
عرض أشرطة صفراء بتحد أكثر
من أي مكان آخر في جنوب
أوكرانيا
الخاضعة لسيطرة روسيا من شبه جزيرة القرم إلى
رموز ابنها للمقاومة الصامتة
لكن المراقبين قاوموا بصخب منذ
البداية
بعد أن تم إسكات الفرصة المبكرة لأهلها
وعندما اختطفت القوات الروسية عمدة البلدة
في أوائل المسيرة
تحول بعض السكان المحليين إلى المقاومة المسلحة
، كان
الوضع خطيرًا للغاية الآن في
أوكرانيا.
يقول زاباريزا إيفان فيدوروف الخاضع لسيطرة الحكومة إن موليتوبول لن يستسلم أبدًا
، يمكنهم الاختطاف ، يمكنهم القتل ، لا يمكنهم
القيام ببعض التعذيب ، لكن لا يمكننا تقديم
الدعم لأن مواطنينا لا
يريدون العيش في روسيا ، وأنا أعلم أن
ميلاتوبال سيعود  إلى أوكرانيا ،
سقطت ميليتاربول بسرعة ، وحتى مع
انسحاب القوات الروسية إلى جنوب
وشرق البلاد ظلت على الطريق.
على الجانب الآخر من الخط الذي عزز
روسيا يستخدم أساليب احتلال هجينة ،
مما يعني أن الاتحاد الروسي
يحاول تحديد وتدمير
مراكز المقاومة الثوار الأوكرانيين
، وغالبًا ما يتم الكشف عن هؤلاء الأشخاص
وسيختفون أحيانًا في السجون الروسية.
هذا هو
السبب في أن حركة الشريط الأصفر
أصبحت مفتاحًا وفقًا للمتحدث باسمها في
كييف ،
فقد أخبرني أن الأشرطة تسمح للناس
بتمرير رسالة مفادها أن أوكرانيا
موجودة هنا بأنه لا يوجد
جنوب آخر سوى تحت العلم الأوكراني
هنا في زابوس ، هناك أيضًا إحساس  أن
هذا الخط الفاصل بين
أوكرانيا التي تسيطر عليها روسيا وبقية البلاد يزداد
تشددًا حتى مع استمرارها في المضي
قدمًا ، يمكننا سماع
الصوت المعتاد لنيران المدفعية الصادرة ولكن
يمكننا أيضًا أن نرى أزمة لاجئين ناشئة
للعائلات التي تعيش في سياراتهم.
يحاولون العودة إلى منازلهم الآن في
المدن التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا ميليسا بيل سي إن إن زاباريكا